bonsoir lorsque j'étais jeune
si bien avant votre naissance a aussi
avec le dernier j'étais férus de
psychanalyse en psychanalyse on
considère je le croyais vraiment que la
personne construit elle-même son
symptôme que le symptôme sert à la
personne à se protéger qu'il a un sens
pareil pour les délires on croit que la
personne est complètement dans son
délire avec ça lui sert à quelque chose
et qu'elle l'a fabriqué par elle même
je croyais que comprendre permettait de
résoudre
et puis un soir j'étais bénévole en
accompagnement fin de vie chacun
s'occupe d'eux me peu dans son temps de
loisir et j'accompagnais un vieux
monsieur délirant j'avais été appelé la
par l'infirmier qui s'occupait lui et ce
monsieur délirant était vous savez les
yeux enfin vous savez peut-être pas mais
je vis très il n'était pas là quoi et
brusquement il est là il est là et il
s'adresse à l'infirmier avec sa voix je
peux pas la faire
toi qui t'y moquer de moi pendant des
années quand je faisais n'importe quoi
alors pendant que je meurs tu sors ça
met l'ambiance
il se tourne vers moi et il fait toi tu
as l'air gentil tu peux rester comme ils
disent les ados mais euh moi j'étais
complètement abasourdis et ce monsieur
avant de mourir on m'a expliqué que
pendant des années il était conscient
d'être en train de délirer il pouvait
pas s'en empêcher
c'était plus fort que lui ils vivaient
un enfer
ce soir là tout ce en quoi je croyais
s'est effondré alors j'ai arrêté la
psychose fouet puis j'ai arrêté la
psychanalyse je pouvais plus j'ai fait
plein de choses et puis progressivement
je suis revenu à la psycho à l'aide des
gens qui vont pas bien mais là je suis
parti sur les neurosciences
voici un schéma de deux cerveaux en
coupe
quand on s'occupe des neurosciences on
tombe immanquablement sur les travaux de
antonio rodrigo damasio l'état travaux
de damasio mettre complètement à plat
l'intelligence l'intelligence n'est
qu'un effet secondaire des émotions
la plupart des comportements sont
déclenchés de façon automatique par le
cerveau le reptilien déclenché plein de
ré de comportement automatique vous
connaissez tous vous avez froid vous
tremblez le limbique déclenché des
comportements automatique vous attendez
une super nouvelle
vous la recevez way en matière de sang
ça vole pas haut et le neocortex ne
reçoit l'information que bien après tout
ça bouleversée encore les choses
j'ai été plus loin et je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait trois origines au mal être
dont deux dans le cerveau la première
origine du mal est ce sont des peurs qui
restent stockées dans le cerveau la
deuxième ce sont des culpabilités et la
troisième c'est un peu partout dans le
corps des tensions et lorsqu'une perth a
établi il ya des tensions dans le corps
et lorsqu'une culpabilité s'établit à
des tensions dans le corps j'ai continué
mes recherches je suis tombé sur les
travaux passionnants de bain chabal libé
et de patrick a gardé français et ces
gens là explique quelque chose de
fascinant c'est à dire que la plupart du
temps nous croyons
décidée alors qu'en fait notre cerveau a
déjà commencé à faire les choses
notre cerveau commence un mouvement est
ensuite consciemment on décide de faire
ce mouvement par exemple vous êtes en
voiture vous décidez de passer la marche
arrière et vous constatez que votre main
elle est déjà sur le changement de
vitesse en fait les fois où nous
décidons réellement notre comportement
c'est assez rare
alors j'ai mélangé ça et d'autres choses
et j'ai créé un concept oignons
scientifique très important c'est pas du
latin mais presque le cra bouillie
legras bouillie c'est quoi
c'est un comportement involontaire qui
est déclenchée par de la peur de la
culpabilité ou les tensions qui a dans
le corps et ensuite on peut quand vous
combinez bien entendu la personne qui
déclenche ingrat bouillie en est la
première victime
elle constate son gras bouillie et elle
peut pas s'en empêcher
alors cette notion de gras bouillie ses
recherches de peur et de culpabilité
ça a permis de soigner de façon très
efficace et un armement des gens qui
n'allaient pas bien et ce de façon assez
rapide mais je sentais qu'il y avait
encore moyens d'aller plus loin
et puis un jour j'avais rendu service à
un copain et
je mets venus un truc que j'avais appris
à la fac à la fac on nous apprend que si
on fait quelque chose c'est pour qu'on
nous aime
un gamin il pose problème c'est pour
qu'on s'occupe de lui alors que moi mon
copain j'ai rendu service parce que
j'aime bien quoi et je me suis dit mais
alors à peu près un type normal je me
suis dis bah en fait si on prend cette
notion là c'est à dire cette notion dont
on fait les choses parce qu'on aime et
non pas pour qu'on nous aime qu'est-ce
qui se passe
alors j'ai pris cette notion là et je
suis parti sur l'idée qu'à la base la
personne l'enfant la personne donne la
personne donne et il ya deux
possibilités
imaginons un enfant qui est là chez lui
il est en train de faire un dessin pour
un de ses parents il est tout content
d'être déjà en train de faire ce dessein
parce qu'il est déjà en train de donner
la personne donne hélas il ya deux
possibilités
si le parent prend le dessin oh merci
mon coeur qu'un s'est mis assez parce
que c'est un mec que c est mignon voyage
elle accueille la personne accueille ce
cadeau l'enfant va se dire que sa façon
de donner sa spontanéité et justes et du
coup servent à développer ce qu'on
appelle la confiance en soi la personne
va aller bien pour les gens qui soigne
les autres c'est une calamité ils
viendront jamais consulté ces gens là
bien
ça c'est le premier cas et puis le
deuxième cas c'est quoi ben c'est tout
simplement quand le don il est refusé
le parent pour une raison qui lui
appartient on fait tous du mieux qu'on
peut dans la vie eh ben il peut pas
recevoir et quand il ne peut pas
recevoir il y à un malentendu
ce malentendu c'est que l'enfant va
croire que c'est sa façon de donner qui
est mauvaise et du coup il va croire que
huit même il est mauvais tout ça c'est
un malentendu
mais on est tous plus ou moins concerné
par ça et comme on veut donner
eh bien il va y avoir la construction
d'un personnage c'est à dire que par
dessus la personne va se créer le
personnage et on va croire que la
personne elle est mauvaise on va croire
que la personne elle fait des gras
bouillie à gogo et du coup c'est pour ça
qu'on va renforcer le personnage pour
protéger les autres autour de nous
exemple je rentre du travail
fatigué ma fille on va dire quatre ans
vient vers moi me faire un bisou le
bisou
et puis je vais m'asseoir dans la grande
pièce je n'ai qu'une seule envie c'est
être tranquille relief fallait pas faire
d'enfant et qu'est-ce qui se passe et
bah ma fille elle vient vers moi et elle
m'amène le jeu avec lequel à ce moment
là où souvent et moi je suis fatigué
alors je refuse je fais ça gentiment
mais je refuse alors ma fille va dans là
qu elle va ranger son jouet quand même
les biens d'une chute
elle va dans la cuisine et la badaboum
elle fait une bêtise
qu'est ce qui s'est passé quand elle m'a
vu arriver
ma fille est venue me faire un bisou
pourquoi pour me tourner de l'amour
c'est spontané c'est la personne n'est
venu me donner de l'amour et je suis
fait un bisou nous on est là en faisant
un bisou
elle a ressenti que j'étais fatigué et
en plus c'est confirmé puisque après
elle me voit assis sur le canapé dans la
grande pièce alors elle se dit papa ne
va pas bien
vais m'occuper de lui ah oui et à 4 ans
comment est ce qu'elle peut faire et
brun avec le jeu et donc elle m'amène le
jeu elle est dans son élan elle est en
train de donner et moi qu'est ce que je
fais je lui dis non hélas elle elle
imagine qu'elle est nul qu elle est
incapable d'aimer et d'aider pas pas
correctement alors ça fait monter de la
culpabilité et se demandent même qu'elle
gras bouille il a bien pu commettre
alors elle va dans la cuisine deux
minutes après et là c'est plus fort
qu'elle sa culpabilité déclencha ingrat
bouillie nous sommes tous plus ou moins
concernés par ce mécanisme
nous sommes tous plus ou moins avec la
personne qui s'est effacé au profit d'un
personnage tout ça par amour et nous
passons notre temps à protéger les
autres du monstre parfois ou au moins de
la mauvaise personne que nous croyons
être et tout ça repose sur un malentendu
j'en étais là dans mes travaux quand
j'ai entendu à la radio une émission où
l'invité c'était monsieur françois
roustan monsieur françois roustan était
un grand monsieur de la psychanalyse
puis ensuite de l'hypnose est ce que
j'ai entendu à ce soir-là a bouleversé
ma vie jusqu'ici
jusqu'ici ce que je connaissais de
l'hypnose c'est est ce que tout un
chacun connaît
vous voulez être quelqu'un de bien alors
quelqu'un de bien ça ne fume pas quand
on est quelqu'un de bien on ne fume pas
donc vous allez voir l'hypno et l'hypno
il va bloquer le comportement fumée
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce que je
connaissais c'était des gens extrêmement
performants qu'ils étaient capables de
vous aider à fabriquer à optimiser le
personnage que vous voulez ce sont des
gens qui sont capables et c'est colossal
ils sont capables de vous aider à
devenir qui vous voulez être sauf que
moi ça ça m'intéressait pas
et la démarche de roustan c'était autre
chose c'était de vous aider à devenir
qui vous êtes réellement
et pour ça il s'agit d'enlever il s'agit
de déconstruire le personnage et le
personnage alors oui j'ai oublié quand
même le titre
on a appelé ça line aux thérapies et
donc quand même le personnage il est
construit sur des peurs des culpabilités
plein de tension et il est construit sur
des images de comment il faut être et
des images de comment il faut paraître
faut pas être nulle du coup il ya plein
de gens ils ont tellement peur d'être
nul qui vont rien faire comme ça on est
pas nul on n'a rien fait
faut pas être méchant alors il ya des
gens ils sont gentils non pas par choix
d'être gentil mais par peur d'être
méchant etc et on peut y aller et c'est
alors la une aux thérapies comment ça
fonctionne et donc il ya pardo il ya ces
images et il ya des tensions partout
dans le corps alors là hinault thérapie
comment ça fonctionne pas le patient
arrive on discute et je vais repéré l'aï
nos thérapeutes var ps qu'on est
plusieurs maintenant va repérer deux
choses principalement d'abord les images
les interdits dans laquelle la personne
se débat et deuxièmement les moments de
tension important dans la vie de la
personne et ensuite qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va faire de l'hypnose alors je
suis désolé je vais pas vous faire une
hypnose collectif simplement si vous
suivez ce que j'explique chez vous vous
pourrez vous faire des auto hypnose
parce que l'hypnose c'est pas compliqué
alors pour partir en hypnose qui indique
ne loue pas qu'ils allaient y noter
rappeuse ou pas il suffit de mettre la
main comme ça la droite si vous êtes
droitier la gauche si vous êtes gaucher
et vous obligez vos yeux à rester fixé
sur un point ça c'est très simple il
suffit d'être un peu têtu et je suis
donc d'obliger les yeux à rester fixé
sur ce point c'est à dire qu'on
contrarie le fait que normalement les
yeux il balaye le champ là on reste fixé
sur ce point qu'est ce qui va se passer
il ya la lumière qui a renvoyé
les yeux quinté repas de sape tout ça
fait une image dans l'air visuel l'air
visuelle elle reçoit sans arrêt la même
information
elle comprend rien et comme elle
comprend rien elle va déformer l'image
va faire des essais alors en général
c'est un flou il ya un léger flou qui
apparaît ça peut faire des trucs
bizarres il ya quelques temps il ya un
monsieur il m'a dit j'ai l'impression
que ma main devient verte
bon c'est comme ça bon c'était bien
c'est que ça marchait et donc la
personne la personne à l'image qui se
déstabiliser le fait que ça se
déstabilise ça lance un signal d alarme
dans le cerveau qui va créer l'état
d'hypnose
en fait on fixe le point on attend que
ça se déstabilise et on va faire
descendre les choses dans le bas du
cerveau ça paraît logique puisque ça
descend et est donc on va demander à la
main ou 20 pardon on va attendre qu'elle
bouge tout seul vers le visage comme une
activité réflexe alors c'est plus ou
moins longue pour ça on peut pas le
faire là et au bout d'un moment la main
se met en mouvement en général par a
couvert la main vers le visage up la
personne on lui demande de fermer les
yeux elle est dans un état d'hypnose
suffisants pour travailler
c'est pas compliqué si on veut en
rajouter pour cela jouer on peut aussi
demander à la main gauche de monter tout
seul ça marche de temps en temps et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
une fois que la personne elle est sous
hypnose mais bien une fois que la
personne elle est sous hypnose
on va d'abord activer les interdits que
la personne a tout simplement pour que
le cerveau constate que les interdits
servent à rien c'est à dire qu'on va lui
demander de se laisser gentiment
confortablement installés dont je suis
méchant par exemple ou dans je suis nul
et ça va faire monter des tensions dans
le corps parce que c'est ça qui est
important est la personne à avoir
l'impression un petit peu qu'elle est
prise dans un étau elle va avoir c'est
pas agréable
leno thérapie des fois c'est pas drôle
et donc la personne elle va être là
comme ça ça va monter de plus en plus
fort et on laisse le corps faire à sa
façon
tout simplement parce que le corps et
c'est bien mieux que nous n'observons il
sait des trucs mais pas tant que ça le
corps il en sait beaucoup plus
et du coup qu'est ce qui se passe la
personne au bout d'un moment
eh bien il ya plus de tension la tension
monte dans le corps la personne est
envahie par de la tension complètement
crispé puis hop ça tombe alors on
recommence encore et donc la personne a
rarement honte et ça jusqu'à ce qu'il se
passe plus rien soit en une seule séance
en plusieurs fois mais jusqu'à ce qu'il
n'y ait plus de manifestations de
tension est comme ça qu'est ce qu'il va
se passer
la personne à l'avenir elle sera libre
elle sera libre d'être gentil d'être
indifférence d'être méchantes la
personne elle sera libre d'être nul ou
pas etc
et puis ensuite on va faire l'autre
partie la partie la plus importante
c'est à dire qu'on va s'adresser
directement au corps et on va demander
aux corps d'enlever les tensions qui
sont présents dans la personne ya de ça
un moment il y avait une dame qui était
venu me voir et puis bah voilà el al est
extrêmement mal christ pas nier que
machin etc
elle souffrait énormément depuis qu'elle
avait l'âge de 16 ans et elle savait pas
pourquoi l'europe fixer un point ta ta
ta elle par souci pneus et je demande
simplement à son corps d'enlever les
tensions qui se sont accumulés sais pas
pourquoi lorsqu'elle avait 16 ans la
personne à une montée tension et elle se
met à pleurer
elle se met à pleurer elle avait pas
pleurer en fait depuis l'âge de 16 ans
elle se met à pleurer c'était
spectaculaire alors dans mon bureau il
ya tout le temps plein de boîtes de
mouchoirs et donc
je une fois qu est ce qu a que les
pleurs se calme un peu
monsieur demande aux cordes à nouveau
faire monter les tensions il en restait
un tout petit peu ont fini de nettoyer
ça et puis la séance était fini quelques
temps après elle m'a appelée el al est
extrêmement bien
c'est extrêmement simple la personne
le personnage tout ça ça repose sur des
tensions aller chira état d'hypnose et
on enlève le personnage on laisse la
personne revenir alors fait d auto
hypnose et y ait des pratiques qui
laisse le corps retrouvé sa spontanéité
le lâcher prise et vous découvrirez
quelque chose on est entre nous vous
découvrirez quelque chose que moi je
connais bien autant thérapeute plus vous
deviendrez la personne que vous n'êtes
plus vous découvrirez que vous êtes
fondamentalement quelqu'un de
sympathique chez vous remercie
[Applaudissements]